Classes have features. By that we mean its attributes, and its, its operations.
While classes, really describe the real world, that is,
the problem that you're solving, features are something that are going to end up
inside the computer. Obviously, your attributes are going to translate,
into instance variables in your object oriented programing language. And
your operations are going to be translated into methods.
We're going to look a little bit at the attributes and the operations.
But, in general. In addition to the names of the attributes and operations,
we are going to have some type of information. And possibly also some, some
names for the attributes so that they can be referred to in, in, in your models.